voisins le bretonneux se situe au
carrefour des axes routiers qui relie la
vallée de chevreuse à versailles et
saint quentin en yvelines le
développement du plateau de saclay fait
que chaque jour cette circulation
augmente dans la commune pour mettre fin
aux embouteillages et la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux propose une
solution créer une voie de contournement
passant par magny les hameaux
afin de soulager la circulation sur la d
36 où on s'est dit ça arrange ça peut
arranger ses habitants aussi c'est à
dire ça peut leur éviter aussi des
bouchons des embouteillages mais il ya
vraiment la question environnementale
qui est très prégnante et que qui n'est
pas contournable à ce niveau alors est
ce que quand la ligne 18 va arriver est
ce que ça peu cette nature à débloquer
des choses ou a poussé l'état à vous
aider dans d'autres solutions
aujourd'hui j'ai pas la réponse une idée
communiqué dans le journal municipal de
septembre sans en avertir le maire de
magny les hameaux
j'étais surpris de peut-être
propositions mais surtout le lendemain
je me suis aperçu en lisant le magazine
municipal de voisins-le-bretonneux que
cette solution elle avait déjà été
disputées largement en amont avec le
département avec le député également ce
que j'ai trouvé particulièrement
irrespectueux dans le cadre des
relations intercommunales qu'on peut
avoir
et puis je considère que c'est pas comme
ça qu'on travaille
la proposition implique de construire un
viaduc en pleine zone forestière classée
natura 2000 et d'ouvrir une nouvelle
voie de circulation au travers du parc
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
une conférence de presse commune inédite
a été organisée entre les groupes
d'opposition de voisins-le-bretonneux il
demande d'être associés au travail de la
ville sur la circulation
nous arrivons à un moment important de
la vie de notre vie nous avons un projet
à la remise 500 logements et nous avons
un carrefour qui inadaptée nous avons
pas le début d'un projet concernant ce
carrefour vous avez la rue de la
mérantaise où il véhicule circule entre
7h30 et 8h30
que faisons nous il est temps d'agir et
c'est ce que
disons agissons ensemble pour voisin les
deux maires partage toutefois le même
objectif désengorger les routes des
voitures qui traversent en nombre leurs
communes